- Good morning Believe Nation.
Todays message is Think For Yourself.
Over to you Tyler, The Creator.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- We live in a society where
a lot of people are followers
and they can't, you know,
make their set opinions.
Like I have friends goin'
to college for stuff that
their parents want them to go for.
And they're not even happy or anything.
But they're just tryin' to
please them and in the long run,
like,
I mean,
what's going to be there?
Your parents die and
you're stuck there like.
(laughs)
Payin' debt, payin'
debt for somethin' that
you didn't even want to
learn in the first place.
So, I just try to tell people
to just think for themselves
and they'll be way
happier in the long run.
- So listen, I think as we grow up,
we are influenced by our parents
and our family and our friends
and the people around us.
Right?
You think the way your parents think.
You've got the values
that your parents have.
If you think money's
evil, it's probably 'cause
your parents thought money's evil.
If you think money will solve everything
it's because your parents thought
money will solve everything.
You have the mindset, the values
and beliefs of your parents.
It's what it is.
And they did it out of love.
Chances are, they loved you, you know.
Unless they didn't.
But they loved you and it was
all out of good intentions.
And you now have their mindset.
Great.
At some point along your
path, you need to break free
and understand that this is
your life that you're living,
and not for anybody else.
If you are in a job, if
you are in a school class,
if you're taking something only because
somebody else wants you to
do it, and you realize that.
Then it's on you.
Right?
At some point, you need
to break free and say,
this is my life!
I want to live my version
of my life and not yours.
And it doesn't have to
be angry and aggressive.
Right?
It can come from a place of understanding.
And if you look at some of
the most successful people
in the world, it came
from breaking free of what
their parents thought
they should do, right?
Michael Dell started Dell Computers.
His parents wanted him to be a doctor.
He was a doctor.
He went to school to be a doctor.
He was starting his computer business
on the side and it started to do well.
And he said to his parents, listen.
Let me take the summer off.
Let me not go intern at
whatever, you know, hospital.
Let me just take the summer
off and focus on my business.
And if it does well, I'll
keep running with it.
If it doesn't, if I don't do
well, if my business tanks,
then I'll go back to school.
And they agreed.
And the business took off.
And he never went back.
And I'm sure his parents are really proud
of him now for what he's done.
And it's the same story over and
over and over and over again.
I think of the founder
of Sony, Akio Morita,
whose 11 generations of sake breweries.
And he was expected to take over the
business as the eldest son.
And you look at Japanese culture as being
super rigid, right?
You have to follow the structure.
It's family honor.
You need to take over
this business for 11 generations.
And he said, no!
I want to start my own tech company.
Which led to Sony.
Which led to reshaping
the Japanese economy.
You know, at some point,
you need to decide
that, I'm taking
accountability for my life,
that I'm not going to just listen to what
other people want for me.
And that you accept responsibility too!
That you claim the
responsibility for when things
work out and when they don't work out too.
If it doesn't work out,
if that new business
doesn't work out, you can't
go blame your parents.
You can't go blame the president.
You can't go blame your lack of resources.
It's on you.
Taking that personal accountability.
And yes, you can take
feedback from other people.
You can still listen to your parents, or
friends, or whoever it is if
it helps you along your path.
But at the end of the day,
it's a powerful day
when you decide
that you are in charge of your life.
You and only you.
You're responsible for your life.
You're accountable for your actions.
You and only you.
That's a powerful day.
And I hope that day's coming soon for you
if it hasn't already happened.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious.
What was the hardest
decision you ever had to make
to think for yourself
as opposed to somebody
else's expectations?
What was that decision you had to make.
Leave it in a comment below.
Curious to find out.
Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Now we're also looking at making a
top-10 moves for success
for Tyler, The Creator.
Here's a sneak peek at some
of the clips we're looking at.
I'd love to get your feedback.
Do you like it?
Do you not?
Tell me below.
- When you think about
catalog, when you go in
and do Cherry Bomb the album,
are you thinkin' now like,
Man, I got so much out there
that, not that you're in
competition with yourself,
but is there a expectation,
is there a pressure,
and what's the process
of goin' into an album?
- I just try to be better than
I just try to make the music
it's like songs that I'm like,
damn, I would never make
a song better than that.
I would never make a song
better than Stevie Wonder's
Where Were You When I Need You.
So I always use that
like, God dang, I have
to make somethin' good like that!
And that's what pushes me
and the fact that in my own head,
I think I will never
make something as good as
the songs that I love will always
and that's that thing I said.
- Give you some excuse
to step into.
- I can never grasp it
so I'll always push myself.
That's why,
I don't know what the
word potential means.
'Cause potential, that's a gap.
I mean, you stop.
That's a wall.
I don't know what that
means so I'll always
push myself harder, and
whether people like it or not,
at least for me, I'm trying
things and trying to be better.
I think a lot of people
are forgetting that.
A lot of people, especially in rap,
it's either like,
for the most part, people are like,
Where's the deep lyrics?
What does he mean?
I want, I need substance.
But a lot of things are feelin'.
That's why, even though
I'm not a fan of a lot of
the popular maybe trap music or whatever.
It's all feelin.'
That shit feels good.
So what they say, it's
just a good feelin.'
At least on my album, every
song is like a photo for me.
Every song is like a moment.
It's a mood.
You know, it's, Blow
My Load is two minutes
of just and eatin' pussy.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- That's what it sounds like.
- That's the score for that.
Every song for me is a score
for moments in my life.
- And it's visual to you.
- Yeah.
I'm very, so, Two Seater?
That's what it sounds like driving from
Hollywood to where I live during
the sunset in LA.
That's actually my car noise.
I recorded on my phone.
That's what it.
Everything I'm talkin' about
on that song is real life.
Doin' 100 on the street but its OK
'cause my car is a stock,
my brakes are good.
Cherry Bomb the song, the crazy one?
That's what it sounds like
when I'm in mosh pits.
Sounds like, you know?
Deathcamp sounds like that.
Okaga, the last song,
sounds like that moment when
you're with someone that you really like
and time doesn't matter.
And you're just enjoying company.
And you're just like, we
should just leave this place
and fly.
- And never come back.
- Smuckers sounds like God and, like.
God, like I'm the man.
Keep Da O's sounds like this.
This is Keep Da O's.
This is that right there?
This shit right here?
The skating down the street with.
That's what Keep Da O's sounds like.
And my verse on there is
about knowing I could lose all of this.
And I need to make sure
I'm focused and shit.
That's always in the back of my mind.
Fucking Young sounds like
being in a sunflower field.
That's why it's in the video.
- Yeah it does.
It does.
- Brown Stains with Q sounds like a sherm.
That's what PCP sounds
like, when the nigga flips.
Like that's why I's
just chillin' and shit.
Then out of nowhere it's like, boom boom.
That's the feeling of it.
And a lot of people are
forgetting what feeling is.
All they want is deep lyrics.
Or some bullshit that.
It's feeling.
- You've been successful
for a few years now.
Have you ever had a regular job?
- I worked at a Starbucks and Fed Ex.
And oh my God.
(laughs)
Horrible.
- Oh was it really bad?
- Starbucks was cool 'cause I stole
cheese danishes every day.
(laughs)
- Fed Ex was so depressing.
It was just.
The spirit there.
Just older dudes like
just pushing boxes but OK with it.
(laughs)
And it scared the livin' hell out of me.
So I quit after a week and four days.
- How long did you work at Starbucks?
- Two and a half years.
- Oh.
- And this lady named Cindy,
she was a new manager.
She hated on me and she fired me.
And I hope she's watching
'cause I still hate her.
(laughs)
I hate you Cindy.
- Cindy, eh?
- I hate you so much.
(host laughs)
I hate you Cindy!
- Is Cindy aware of your success?
- I hope.
I hope, her firing me was the greatest
moment of my life!
- Was it really?
- Ah, my chains was free!
- Wow!
How did she do it?
Did she sit you down and
say, it's time to go?
- Nah.
Dude, somebody, one of the shift managers
warned me like 10 minutes
before she fired me.
So I had nine minutes to call my mom,
askin' her what I should do.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
It was tight.
I didn't even,
like, somebody was like, Yo.
You gettin' fired in nine minutes boy.
- And what did your mom tell you to do?
- First she was going
to sue the Starbucks.
(laughs)
Then we figured out
they did nothin' wrong.
(laughs)
- That's no reason not to sue.
- So OK.
That was nine minutes.
So I had about four minutes
left to figure out what to do.
So, I manned up and said, all right.
I'll get fired, and I ate
like three cheese danishes.
(laughs)
- You did the right thing.